how do I build a CI CD Pipeline on
Google Cloud our heroic developer
decides to throw some code for their
super cool container based app into
Cloud Source repositories they got to
include some funky ammo and kubernetes
manifest once the code is in things get
wild any changes trigger a container
build and the build metadata goes into
the magical world of cloud storage
bucket now we can't have any dodgy
containers floating around so the build
containers go through some serious
security scanning as they get stored in
artifact registry and if they pass they
get a fancy signature from binary
authorization but wait there is more we
gotta test these babies out before
they're ready for the big show Cloud
deploy pushes the releases to developer
and test environments finally after all
that fussing or precious containers are
ready for the big leagues they get
rolled out into the production
environment for users to enjoy